star wars fans argue so much about the
successes of the franchise it's easy to
let the true failures slip your mind the
connect game the 3d re-releases detours
those and more ahead
if you thought star wars didn't enter
the world of animated television until
the 21st century you'd be wrong but you
wouldn't be alone either after all
lucasfilm has largely buried the
company's first foray into this
particular genre one that occurred as
far back as the 1980s
that's when star wars droids attempted
to make waves in the world of saturday
morning programming however the show
struggled for a number of reasons for
one it had a pretty hefty price tag with
each episode running between five
hundred thousand and six hundred
thousand dollars and while c-3po and
r2d2 are always a hit with the fans none
of the side characters were really
clicking artist brian lemay later told
sci-fi wire
the secondary characters that the droids
were involved with were not really
strong characters they were just these
characters that were thrown in to carry
them through an adventure of sorts
worse still this intensely
family-friendly show lacked any sort of
edge future star wars cartoons wouldn't
be afraid to spice things up a little
but droids was allowed no such
flourishes the man behind c-3po anthony
daniels even once complained
you can't put a custard pie in my face
because of what they call imitative
behavior they don't want children saying
oh we saw it on the cartoon we thought
it was okay
perhaps unsurprisingly droids didn't
last more than a single season
while the clone wars was on the air
plans got underway for the show to spin
off into another animated show a series
of clone wars episodes focusing on a
collection of young padawans aired
during the series fifth season in early
2012. this arc was supposed to establish
a new group of characters who would
later star in their own show the
episodes that introduced these figures
centered on the younglings trying to
build their own lightsabers with the
help of a socatano and a wise droid
voiced by david tennant so let us begin
there is much more work to be done
there was enough confidence in this
premise that the episodes were even
planned to air as a single tv movie
before leading into a tv show mirroring
the way in which clone wars itself was
introduced to the world however for
reasons unknown this storyline was
relegated to a string of traditional
episodes while the spin-off was put on
the back burner this was in spite of the
new program being something of a passion
project for george lucas himself the
production fell further into the rear
view once disney bought lucasfilm and
set up its own slate of kid-oriented
star wars cartoons
with the creation of xbox's connect a
new world of video game possibilities
suddenly opened up gaming that relied on
your body movements rather than a
controller was a prospect that seemed so
exciting at the time and it wasn't long
before thoughts turned to how the star
wars universe could utilize this idea
after all star wars and video games have
been a lucrative pairing for decades now
so why not embrace this new technology
unfortunately rather than using the
kinect controllers to make a new
action-adventure title lucasarts
produced connect star wars a grab bag of
different play modes ranging from
padawan training to
dance-offs
inevitably connect star wars failed to
connect with the general public and
critics were less than impressed some
praise was offered for certain aspects
of the gameplay but the project just
didn't come together like it was
supposed to as it stands the only part
of connect star wars to have had any
lasting impact is one of its dance off
tunes titled i'm han solo this parody of
ryden solo became infamous with the av
club calling it quote one of the worst
pieces of star wars licensing ever not
great as far as legacies go
for a moment it looked like the force
unleashed was the next big step for the
star wars franchise the beloved 2008
video game followed the tale of
starkiller the hidden apprentice of
darth vader and it really seemed like
this premise might inspire all kinds of
compelling storytelling for years to
come sadly much of that potential was
sucked away by its sequel the force
unleashed too this 2010 title received
mixed marks from critics with much of
the criticism being directed at the
writing and its awkward attempt at a
cliffhanger ending still many star wars
properties have come up short critically
before going on to spawn further sequels
and spin-offs the real kiss of death for
the force unleashed 2 was its sales
numbers which proved to be incredibly
underwhelming with all these factors at
play the continuing importance of the
force unleashed franchise began to
diminish
eventually this once promising new
avenue for star wars storytelling
sputtered out completely as the disney
purchase of lucasfilm led to the
prioritization of newer projects even
without that merger though it's doubtful
that the force unleashed two could ever
have generated enough of a positive
response to keep the series going
initially the second star wars spin-off
movie after rogue one wasn't going to be
han solo's origin story instead it was
supposed to be a boba fett feature the
controversial director josh trank was
once set to helm the production but the
project was put on the back burner once
tranq stepped away the filmmaker opened
up in may 2020 explaining i quit because
i knew i was going to be fired if i
didn't quit still this wasn't the end of
the story for fett's solo movie for a
brief moment in may 2018 a rumor that
logan director james mangold stepped in
to take over from trank renewed public
interest in the project but this
interest was short-lived in the wake of
solo coming up short at the box office
spin-off star wars movies were put on
hold in favor of expanding the franchise
through event tv shows on disney plus
this meant that the boba fett movie was
once again kicked to the curb eventually
fett would make his way into disney's
star wars galaxy in the second season of
the mandalorian and his own series the
book of boba fett
i'm a simple man making his way through
the galaxy
like my father before me at the start of
the 2010s it looked like theatrical 3d
re-releases of classic movies were about
to become a big thing with the original
lion king becoming a surprise hit when
it was released in 3d in september 2011
the stage seemed set for a series of
subsequent 3d re-releases to make a
similar killing at the box office these
included the phantom menace 3d which was
planned as the start of an ambitious
push to re-release all six original star
wars movies in a whole new dimension
sadly the phantom menace 3d didn't
exactly blow the doors off the box
office sure its worldwide gross wasn't
enough to push the movie's lifetime haul
past the one billion dollar threshold
but that was its only accomplishment
after a decent opening weekend the movie
made just less than half of what the
lion king 3d had accumulated at the
domestic box office autumn 2013 release
dates were set for 3d re-releases of the
other two star wars prequel films but
they were eventually pulled after disney
bought lucasfilm as a result the
studio's ambitious plans have been left
unrealized
today star wars the clone wars is known
as a tv show that took major risks by
focusing on unsung supporting characters
in the franchise and even exploring some
outright esoteric concepts but you have
to walk before you can run and most
animated programs begin their runs with
more awkward episodes rarely though do
these more imperfect episodes play out
on the big screen but such was the case
for the theatrical film star wars the
clone wars released in 2008 the clone
wars was meant to serve as a feature
linked pilot for the series however the
film's animation style could never hope
to compete with the kind of visuals seen
in its big budget competitors worse this
movie utilized a more juvenile sense of
humor and dialogue that later seasons of
the clone wars would jettison all in all
the whole project was quite poorly
thought out and it didn't even bring in
much money for the studio cementing the
project as an underwhelming beginning to
a beloved tv series
george lucas got along so well with the
team behind the trio of robot chicken
star wars specials that he assembled the
same group in the late 2000s for a new
sci-fi project uh as the creator of uh
mara jade
wait
i am not the creator of our jade and i
want you to get out of this office right
now this was star wars detours an
animated tv show that would take a
satirical spin on many of the series
beloved characters clips of the program
were shown at star wars celebration in
2012 and included such antics as obi-wan
kenobi becoming a comedian and admiral
akbar failing to think of the word trap
just two months after the world
discovered detours however disney bought
lucasfilm and the whole landscape of
star wars entertainment changed forever
disney had its own plans for the
franchise of course and none of them
revolved around detours even though
around 40 episodes of the show had been
completed the program was shelved seth
green later confirmed that lucasfilm's
new management just didn't see the show
fitting in with their more
serious-minded plans for the franchise
rumors continue to persist that detours
will eventually drop on disney plus in
the near future but otherwise this
particular project seems to have totally
fizzled out ted i got your vouchers
out
there i'm sorry about that i'm so sorry
lego and star wars have turned out to be
a match made in heaven the two pop
culture properties have been working
together for decades now on everything
from toys to video games to movies so
why shouldn't there eventually be plans
to turn lego star wars into an ongoing
tv show well such a creative endeavor
once emerged through the freemaker
adventures which followed a trio of
siblings who get swept up in the greater
battle between the rebel alliance and
the galactic empire to date this show is
the only instance of a lego star wars
property scoring an ongoing tv program
in a traditional seasonal format with
most other televised lego star wars
properties emerging as either tv
specials or miniseries and given that
the freemaker adventures didn't set the
world on fire that's not surprising
either the show wasn't exactly a massive
flop but it was nowhere near as
impactful as lucasfilm's other animated
shows and it didn't attract the kind of
fan base that the lego star wars video
games have in the end the show lasted
only two seasons
originally the next step for the star
wars franchise after revenge of the sith
wasn't a sequel trilogy but a foray into
the world of television the clone wars
was to begin airing in 2008 and then a
live-action star wars tv show later
named star wars underworld would debut
shortly thereafter the program was set
to explore all kinds of nooks and
crannies of the galaxy far far away it
would cover everything from how han and
chewie met to the origin story of
palpatine the series had grand ambitions
indeed and was personally overseen by
george lucas but underworld never got
off the ground for one simple reason
money the financial strain required to
pull off a production of this scale on a
network tv budget proved too massive to
overcome lucasfilm executive pablo
hidalgo later noted that george lucas
was unable to expand his grady ranch
property to accommodate sound stages
which also forced the show's production
to ground to a halt nowadays shows such
as the mandalorian have made star wars
television practically commonplace in
that sense perhaps star wars underworld
was simply a project ahead of its time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite star wars stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]